I'm sure many of y'all have already
heard of the molecule DNA and it stands
for deoxyribonucleic acid I wrote it out
ahead of time to spare you the pain of
watching me spell this in real time
but it is and I think you already have
an idea this is the basic unit of
heredity or it's in a lot it's what
codes all of our genetic information and
what I want to do in this video because
I think that's kind of common knowledge
that's popular knowledge that oh you
know everything that you know what makes
my hair black or my eyes blue or
whatever that's all somehow encoded in
our DNA but what I want to do in this
video is give you an idea of how
something like DNA a molecule can
actually code for what we are how does
the information one get stored in this
type of a molecule then how does that
actually turn into the proteins that
make up our enzymes and our organs and
our brain cells and everything else so
that that really make us us so this is a
a computer graphics representation of
DNA and I'm sure many of you all have
heard of the double helix double helix
and that's a reference to the structure
that DNA takes and you can see here it's
a double helix it's a as you can see
here you have two of these lines and
they're intertwined each other you see
there that's one of them and then you
see another one in intertwined like that
and then they're connected by you can
almost views it's like these bridges
between the two between the two helixes
and they twist around each other and I
think you get the idea and so the double
helix just describes the the structure
the shape the DNA takes and a-hat leads
to all sorts of interesting
repercussions in terms of how heredity
takes place and and and and and and how
natural selection and variation might
take place as well and actually in the
future I do want to actually read with
you the Watson and Crick's paper on the
double helix where they essentially you
know talk about their discovery and what
the best thing about that paper besides
the fact that it was probably one of the
biggest discoveries in the history of
mankind is that the paper is only
page and a half long and it goes to my
general view that if you have something
good to say it shouldn't take you that
long to say it but with that said let's
think a little bit about how this can
actually generate the proteins and
whatever else that then make up all of
us so right here this is a zoomed up
version of that of that of that graphic
that I just showed you a little bit
earlier and this is each of the helixes
so if you know this is the magenta side
if you unwound this helix right now it
shows that in kind of it's wound state
but if I unwind this helix I'd get one
side would maybe be maybe be this
magenta side of our helix and then one
side is this green side right and if you
twist it up you get back to this drawing
up here and then these bridges that you
see in this drawing and the double helix
those are these connections right here
these are the bridges these are the
bridges now what allows us to to code
information is that the make up the
blocks that make up the bridges are made
of different molecules and the four
different molecules that are made up in
DNA are adenine and it's written here on
this little chart I got all of this from
Wikipedia so if you want more
information I encourage you to go there
adenine they do that that's up here this
is the molecular structure of adenine
it's connected to a sugar right here
ribose I won't go into a deoxyribose
that's where government and then you
have your phosphate group but these kind
of form the the backbone of the DNA the
sugar and the phosphate groups and I'm
not going to go into the microbiology of
it because that's not important right
now for understanding just how does this
intuitively code for what we are so you
have along the backbone which is
identical and we'll talk about they run
in different directions it's called anti
parallel so if this is they label the
ends and I'm not going to go into detail
there but the important thing is is are
these these bases here so you have
adenine and adenine pairs with thymine
adenine pairs with thymine
and you see that up here if you have an
adenine molecule here on adenine base
here it'll pair with thymine this is
called the base pair adenine and thymine
pair with each other if you have thymine
it's going to pair with adenine and then
you have guanine and it pairs with
cytosine so Kuan een guanine and it
pairs with cytosine and the names of
these you should know these names just
because they are almost well if you ever
enter any discussion about about DNA in
base pairs this is you know expected
knowledge but the names of the molecules
and how they're structured we not
important just yet but what's important
is is the fact that there are four of
them and that they are they essentially
code information so you can view the one
of these strands in kind of a simplified
way you could just see view it as a
strand of so this one if I it has an
adenine adenine and then it has a
cytosine as a cytosine then it has a
guanine it's a guanine they did it in
purple and then it has a I don't has a
thymine not a guanine so it has a
thymine in purple and then in blue it
has a guanine so this this strand right
here codes ACTG
and if you were to code the opposite
side of the strand you could immediately
I don't even have to look here I can
look at this side say okay adenine will
pair with thymine guanine cytosine pairs
with with guanine thymine pairs with
adenine and guanine pairs with cytosine
so they're complementary strands so if
you think about it they're really coding
the same thing if you have one of them
you have all of the information for the
other now in our DNA in a human's DNA so
you might say hey you know Sal how do I
go from how do I go from these little
you know little chains of these
molecules that ya mean it's like you
know how does that turn into me how does
that turn into this complex organism and
the simple answer is as well you have
the human genome has 3 billion of these
base pairs 3 billion 3 billion
base-pairs and that's actually just in
half of your chromosomes and I'll tell
you maybe in this video or a future
video while we only consider half of
your chromosomes and that's because
essentially all of you have two pair you
have a pair of every chromosome I'll
talk more in more detail about that and
this number to some people they might
say I'm only it only takes three billion
pieces of you know three billion base
pairs to describe Who I am and to some
people would say wow I it takes three
billion base pairs to describe why I'd
ever thought I was that complex so
depending on your point of view this is
either a large or a small number but
when you take these three billion base
pairs you're actually encoding all of
the information that it takes to make in
this case a human being and actually it
turns out a lot of primates don't have
that many different base pairs in human
beings and if you a fewer it's actually
what the amazing thing is even things
like roundworms and fruit flies also
number in the well a surprisingly large
fraction of the base pairs of a human
being I maybe I'll do another video
where I go into comparative biology but
how does this how does these these base
pairs actually lead to proteins I mean
it's fair enough that's information it's
like you can view these as ones and
zeros and some type of computer language
but really they're not just ones and
zeros because it can take on four
different values they can take on you
know a a a T a C or a G so you could
think of them as zero ones twos and
threes but I won't go into that whole
aspect of it just now so how does that
actually code code information so DNA
when it actually transcribes transcribe
something it's a the process is called
transcription let me just do a trans
description and I'm going to do a pretty
gross simplification of it but I think
it'll give you the gist of how it codes
for proteins so what happens when
transcription happens is that these two
strands split up and one of the strands
let me just take one of them let's say
it looks like this I'll do it all in one
color let's say it's just a TGG
a CG I'm just making up stuff T a let's
say that that's the strand that got
split up and what happens is it
transcribes it and I won't say itself
there's there's a whole bunch of enzymes
and proteins and it's a you know a whole
bunch of chemical reactions that I have
to happen but this DNA essentially
transcribes a complementary mRNA and
mRNA and I'll introduce RNA that are na
it's essentially the exact same thing as
well the word is ribonucleic acid so
it's literally you get rid of the deoxy
so you can kind of say it's got its oxy
and this ribonucleic acid but it's very
similar to DNA it codes in the exact
same way and the only difference between
RNA instead of a thymine instead of a
thymine it has something called a uracil
a year or so so every place where you
would have expected a thymine it'll have
you would have expected a T you'll now
see a u so for example this is this is
the DNA strand then a RNA and mRNA a
messenger RNA strand will be built
complementary to this so it'll be built
let's see with a you normally have
thymine when you're talking DNA but now
we're talking RNA so it'll be a uracil
then an adenine cytosine cytosine
let's see your ass ill then we got a
guanine a cytosine a and adenine and
then we'll have a uracil and so this is
the mRNA strand here and all of this is
occurring inside the nucleus the nucleus
of your cells and we'll do a whole
series of videos in the future about the
the structure of our of our cells but I
think most of us know that our cells and
I'll talk more about eukaryotic and
prokaryotic organisms of future but most
complex organisms they have a cell
nucleus where we have all of our
chromosomes that contain all of our DNA
and so this mRNA then detaches itself
from the DNA that it was transcribed
from and then it leaves the nucleus and
it goes to these structures called
ribosomes and I'm you know I'm
oversimplifying a little bit but at the
ribosomes this mRNA is translated into
proteins so let me do that so let's say
this is so this is the mRNA it was
transcribed from that DNA so let me get
rid of that DNA now I got rid of the DNA
this is the mRNA that we were able to
transcribe from that DNA and they have
these other things called tRNA or
transfer RNA and what these are and this
is this is the really interesting part
so you may or may not know that you know
pretty much everything we are there's
made up of proteins and these proteins
the building blocks of proteins are
amino acids and for those of you who
like to lift weights I'm sure you've
seen ads for amino acid supplements and
things of the like and the reason why
they they talk about amino acids because
those are the building blocks of of
proteins amino acids my son actually has
an allergy to milk protein so we have to
get him a formula that was just pure
amino acids just all of the milk
proteins broken down so if you look at a
protein it's actually it's actually a
chain of these amino acids and usually a
fairly long chain will get it we'll look
at a we'll look at some of some protein
structures in the very near future just
to give you an idea of things it's a
very long chain of these of these amino
acids and they're actually 20 different
amino acids 20 different amino acids are
pretty much the structure of all of our
proteins so let me write that 20 amino
acids amino acids so a very obvious
question is how can these things code
for 20 different amino acids I can only
have four different things in this
little bucket right here and then you
just have to go back to your
combinatorics or if you if you don't if
you can't go back to it watch the play
the playlist on probability and
combinatorics they say okay there's only
four ways that each of these that I can
have for each of these bases there's
only four different bases that I can
have here either an an agree adenine
guanine cytosine or depending on whether
talking about DNA or RNA a uracil or
thymine but how can we increase the
combinations well if we if we include
two of them if we include two bases then
how many combinations can we have well
we have four possibilities here then
we'd have four possibilities here so
we'd have 16 possibilities but that's
still not enough that's still not enough
to code for a for one of twenty amino
acids to say hey this is going to code
for amino acid number five and we'll
talk more about their actual names so
what do we have to do then we have to
use three of them so three of them
there's actually four times four times
four possibilities here so they could
code for 64 different things they can
take on 64 different combinations or
permutations this UAC right here so if
we have three of these bases we can
actually code for an amino acid or
actually it's overkill because we can
actually have 64 combinations here and
there are only 20 amino acids so we can
even have redundant combinations code
for different amino acids for example we
might say that you know let's say and
either this isn't the actual code but
maybe UAC and I should look these up
this codes for amino acid number one and
if it was you a or let's say AAU this
codes for amino acid number two and if
we have let me see if I have I mean I
think you get the idea if I have GGG
this codes for amino acid number ten and
what happens is when this messenger RNA
leaves the nucleus it goes to the
ribosomes and at the ribosomes we're
going to look at that diagram in a in a
few seconds but at the ribosomes let me
take my my same mRNA molecule and
they're much longer than what I'm
showing here this is just a fraction of
an mRNA molecule so I'll take my mRNA
molecule and what they do is they they
essentially act as a template for tRNA
molecules and tRNA molecules are these
are these molecules that have that are
attached to that they're almost like the
trucks for the amino acids so let's say
I have some of
no acid right here and then I have
another amino acid that's right here
like that and then I have another amino
acid that's like that they'll be
attached to tRNA molecule so let's say
that this tRNA molecule is has on it
it's attached so this amino acid is
attached to a tRNA molecule that has the
code on it a let me do it in a darker
color this has the code a u G this one
right here has it on it has the code it
has on it let's see the code let me pick
another one let's say it has G G a C so
what's going to happen when you're in
the ribosome and it's a it's a complex
situation but actually what's happening
isn't too fancy this tRNA and once it's
it wants to bond to this part of the
mRNA why because adenine bonds with
uracil uracil bonds with adenine and
guanine bonds with cytosine so it'll
pull up right here it'll pull up right
next to this thing and actually I should
probably let me see if I can well not
even if I can rotate it but it'll just
pull up right here on an attached to
this mRNA molecule and just this right
here is T RNA tRNA this is mRNA and the
names don't matter I really just want to
give you the big picture idea of how the
proteins are actually formed and this is
an amino acid I know it's called an
amino acid one amino acid five amino
acid 20 this guy he's going to pull up
right here he's the the guanine is
attracted to cytosine and I if you watch
the chemistry videos these are actually
hydrogen bonds that form the base pairs
adenine wants to pull up to Gua your
Aseel cytosine to guanine and so on and
so forth and so once all of these guys
have pulled up let me do that so if once
you once you've pulled up let's say that
this is I could do it up here this is my
mRNA molecule I'm not going to draw the
specifics right there my little tRNA is
pull up pull up next to it and they each
hold a payload right so this this first
one holds this payload right here of
this amino acid
the second holds this payload of this
amino acid and so forth and so on and so
you know I might keep going and there's
another immuno green amino acid here
they don't really don't have those
colors but I'm just just for the sake of
simplicity like that and then the amino
acids bond to each other when they're
held like that close to each other and
this doesn't happen all by itself
the ribosome serves a purpose and there
are enzymes that facilitate this process
but once these guys bond together the
tRNA detaches and you have this chain
this this this chain of amino acids and
then the chain of amino acids starts to
bend around so they have all of these
and it's actually a fascinating I mean
people have done many you know people
spend their life studying how proteins
fold and that's actually where they get
most of their their structural
properties it's not just the chain of
the amino acids but what's more
important is how these amino acids
actually fold so once you fold them they
form these really ultra complex patterns
based on on you know what amino acid is
attracted to what other amino acids and
these very intricate three-dimensional
shapes and what what I took here from
Wikipedia is these are some amino acids
and just to be able to relate this to
the the DNA this right here is insulin
its key and our ability to process
glucose in our body so this right here
is insulin it's a hormone so you know
sometimes you hear people talk about
your immune system sometimes you hear
people talking about your endocrine
system and hormones sometimes your
digestive system but this is hemoglobin
you know the essentially the what makes
what essentially transports our oxygen
in our blood but all of these things are
proteins and all of these little little
folds you see these are a little amino a
mean there's there's there's just little
dots of amino acids and this is just one
well some of these are multiple chains
of amino acids kind of fitting together
like a big puzzle but some of them are
just single chains of amino acids for
like insulin right here this is 50 amino
acids and then once the chain forms at
all it all bundles together and forms
this little this little blob like you
see but the shape of that blob is super
important for insulin being able to
perform the function that it needs to
perform in our in our and our systems
but this right here
is 50 approximately 50 I forgot the
exact number amino acids amino acids
this right here this amino global
immunoglobulin G which is part of our
immune system this is a roughly 1,500
1,500 amino acids amino acids so how
much DNA or how many base pairs have to
code for this well three times as much
right because it took you have to have
three base pairs that code for one amino
acid and actually three base pairs this
is called a codon codon because it codes
for amino acids so three base pairs make
a codon so if you have 50 amino acids
that make up insulin that means you're
going to have to have 50 codons which
means you have to have 150 150 bases
which or 150 of these A's and GS and T's
if you have 1500 amino acids that means
going to have to 1,500 codons which
means you're going to have roughly 4,500
4,500 of these base pairs that code for
it now you might you know there are some
notions that get confused a lot so
everything I went to the kind of the
smallest level of our DNA right here and
this is the level at which well this is
RNA that I'm pointing to right there but
this is the smallest level of DNA and
that's the level at which the
information is actually coded but how
does that relate to things like genes
and chromosomes and and things that you
might talk about in other context and so
these base pairs so let's say the 50 the
150 base pairs that coded for insulin
these make up a gene a gene so and you
know these four hundred forty five
hundred base pairs make up another gene
now all of the genes don't make proteins
but all of the proteins are made by
genes so let's say I have just a bunch
of let me just take a bunch of you know
I'm just make another you know AG and it
goes down down down and you have you
know that
at E and then a/c and a/c and let's say
I have and 45 hundreds of these these
could code for a protein these could
code for protein or they could have all
of these other kind of regulatory
functions telling telling what other
parts of the DNA should and should not
be coded and what the how the DNA
behaves so it becomes super super
complex but this kind of section of our
DNA this is what we refer to as a gene
this is what we refer to as a gene and
the gene can have anywhere I mean from a
couple of hundreds of these base pairs
or these bases to several thousand of
these base pairs now a gene is that part
of our chromosome that codes for a
particular protein or serves a certain
function now there are different
versions of genes right so a gene so
this could you know it's a gross
oversimplification but let maybe they
say this is the gene for this is the
gene for insulin insulin now there might
be you know slight variations in how
insulin can be coded for and I'm kind of
going out of my domain right here
because I don't know if that's true and
maybe I shouldn't just speak
specifically about insulin but it's
coding for some protein but there's
maybe multiple different ways that that
protein can be coded maybe a set of a T
here sometimes there's a see there it
still codes for the same protein it
doesn't change it quite enough but it
that protein acts just a little bit
different it introduced it has a little
bit of it's it's a slight variant I'll
use that word now each variant of this
gene is called an allele allele is a
specific specific variant specific
variant of your gene variant of your
gene now if you take up if you you know
you take these this this is this DNA
chain and you know this this chain over
here let's see this is one base pair and
just so kind of you know this might be
like one base there's another basis is
this maybe this is an adenine and then
this would be a thymine over here in
green this is an add knee this would be
a thymine if this is a you know if right
here this is a guanine then right here
would be a cytosine this would be just a
very
small section if I were to like zoom out
right and let's say we have a big chain
of DNA where each of these little dots
are base pair that I'm drawing here
maybe this section codes for gene one
gene one maybe and then there's some
noise or things that we haven't fully
understood yet and I want to be clear
just with a simple discussion of DNA
we're already kind of approaching the
frontiers of what we know and what we
don't know because there's DNA is hugely
complex and there's all of these
feedback structures and certain genes
tell you to code for other genes and not
to code for other genes and to code
under certain circumstances it's hugely
complex so there's few sections of DNA
that we still don't understand what
exactly they do but then maybe they'll
have another section here that codes for
gene two maybe gene two is a little bit
longer maybe it's a thousand base pairs
but when you take all of these and you
turn it into a and then it it kind of
winds in on itself like this let me do
it so it'll wind up winding in on itself
like this and do all sorts of crazy
things remember this is the holes you
know it completely bundles itself up and
then it looks something like that then
you get a chromosome a chromosome and
just to get an idea of how large a
chromosome is compared to compared to
the actual base pairs chromosome number
one in the human genome so we have 23
pairs if you look at it inside of a
nucleus so let's say that's the nucleus
let's say this is the cell the cell is
much bigger than what I'm showing but we
have 23 pairs of chromosomes we have 23
pairs of chromosomes one two I won't do
all of them and you can actually see
chromosomes in a not too expensive
microscope so we're already getting to a
scale that we can start to look at but
the largest chromosome which is
chromosome number one in the human
genome just to give an idea of how much
information it's packing that thing
right there has 220 million base pairs
so when we're talking about you know
sometimes people talk about chromosomes
and genetics and genes and base pairs
interchangeably but it's very important
to kind of get an idea of scale these
chromosomes are a super long strand of
DNA that's all configured and bundled up
it contains 220 million base-pairs so
the actual elements that are coding for
the information are unbelievably small
relative relative to the chromosome
itself but now that we understand a
little bit and actually I want to take a
look back at this because this is what
you know this kind of blows my mind that
if you just take are those little
combinations of those amino acids you
can form these very intricate very
advanced structures that we're still
fully understanding how they actually
interact with each other and regulate
how are all of our biological processes
work what's even more amazing is that
this this scheme that I've talked about
in this video about DNA to mRNA to tRNA
to these molecules this is true for all
of life on our planet so we all share
the same mechanism of you know me and
this plant we're distant we share that
common root of that we all have DNA is
different as me and that you know Roach
that I might not like to be in the same
room we all share that same common root
of DNA and that all of it codes to
proteins in this exact same way that
there's this commonality amongst all
life that to me is mind-blowing then
even more mind-blowing is how these very
complex shapes are formed by this you
know by the DNA and this isn't
speculation this is I mean you could
this this is observed behavior that
these very I mean this is a fascinating
structure right here but it's just based
on 20 amino acid you can almost view the
amino acid as the legos and and you put
the Legos together and just the chemical
interactions form these these fairly
impressive structures right here so now
that we know a little bit about DNA and
how it codes into protein we can take a
little jump back and talk a little bit
more and about how variation is actually
introduced into a population